what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Tara Erickson I'm so happy
you're gonna be with me on this journey
she has never seen Fantastic Four the
2005 movie I saw this one time opening
night 2005 must have been 14 or 15 Tara
30 35 years old somewhere there I
remembered not really liking it but I've
never seen the sequel to this movie
Fantastic Four rides at the Silver
Surfer so if enough people watch this
and it starts by leaving a like on this
video we'll cover Rise of the Silver
Surfer which will be a brand new watch
for both Tara and myself Tara I'm
surprised you've actually never seen it
I have not seen it and he just threw
down that he was there at the opening of
this movie yeah okay it's the first time
we watch special now special at 14 too
I was not special I was like everything
sucks okay but they are rebooting it in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe what and
yeah these are new this is facts
Fantastic Four is finally coming to the
MCU with it open up the Multiverse and
doing Nostalgia stuff John is covering
Blade with Roxy because he hasn't seen
those movies and I figured I would
complete my Fantastic Four Journey with
Tara here I'm stoked this whole poster
here looks so you like literally know
nothing about Fantastic Four I know
nothing I don't know why because I love
Disney and Marvel but like no I don't I
haven't seen this oh this is gonna be
fun so guys subscribe click that
notification Bell to get notified when
our next movie reactions up on this
channel as always full interaction watch
along where you stick up with your own
copy of Fantastic Four available for our
super sexy rejects oh my God Tara I'm so
sorry
I'm so sorry it was bad and I was
waiting patiently
Victor Von Doom to build a 30-foot
statue of himself it's obviously aimed
at first-time visitors to create
feelings of their smallness besides
Victor's not that bad he's just a little
larger than life this is crazy you know
nothing about Fantastic Four nothing I
know that that guy's from The Shield
though a study conducted in space could
fundamentally Advance our knowledge
about the structure of the human genome
cure countless diseases healthier enough
I don't think I've explained my proposal
fully no I think you have you could tell
he's a villain right he's in dark if
NASA doesn't trust you then why should I
I can't take this man this is business
just work he's right Ben there she is so
beautiful director of genetic research
Susan storm
have you been never better ah cold hard
handshake history oh you know you made a
lot of folks at MIT feel like a junior
high science fair so you'll excuse me if
I say for the moment that guy's face
looks so fake yeah when are we leaving
I'll be scheduling the launch so
oh
sick burn
as far as crew I was hoping Ben could
pilot fish we already have a pilot on
our payroll but you're welcome to ride
shotgun remember my brother John
uh
bad boy Johnny I cannot take orders from
the underwear model oh come on I've been
not washed out of NASA for sneaking two
Victoria's Secret wannabes into a flight
simulator that's fun they crashed it
into a wall when have I ever asked you
to do something you absolutely said you
could not do five times I had it at four
well this makes five you know when I was
young I was a lot more cynical
cause I'm fighting myself going this
feels like a Cheesy comic book I kind of
like it I can handle the ship I can even
handle Mr blonde ambitious I mean who
the hell came up with these Victor did
the synthetics act as a second skin oh
my God
material made from self-regulating
unstable molecules
I've been working on a formula for this
that's great all I really clearly
remember from this movie is one moment
and I will say
I will say when it has happened and it's
just one moment that's all I remember
two moments you got Victor more money
than God stud of the year and you gotta
read world's dumbest smart guy worth
less than a postage stamp but he's got a
big heart this isn't every man
don't propose right now is he gonna do
that is no opening station Shield
[Music]
have these guys been to space before it
seemed really comfortable up there
number one that seemed like such a grand
gesture that I don't think they have
been but then again they do seem comfy
nine minutes 47 seconds
that's impossible it should be seven
hours oh
there it is oh my gosh he was what a
nerd
I'm afraid of taking big steps now it's
time to take the biggest to the fall oh
your relationship will be Von doomed
deadly we need to abort get us close the
shields Ben is still out there we came
here to do a job
Heavens oh
turn around buddy
X guys I'm not gonna make it man you
gotta jump it's the only way
oh my gosh
what are you doing you can't just leave
them out there watch me what oh my God
take that ring and throw it at his face
out jumping it I think he's just like
floating with it
what what what
that oh my God
[Music]
Ah that's cool
I got some nipple chills I got some mine
I got some silly nips right now
I don't think I got that when I was cool
that's why they become
fan well there's like no fat on this
movie what's wrong with me and they've
done everything humanly possible the
best plastic surgeons in the world have
been you had the best give me that
mirror oh God be strong
this ain't gonna look like
oh my God blood panels show no
irradiation good we'll step up this
protocol every four hours yes
ah she still looks great she's so pretty
would like to congratulate you I'm the
fastest free-fall sense of depression we
can't even give your stock away you know
I can turn this around or you're going
to have to Victor or we pull out that's
what she said hahaha
you have a week you're enjoying this
aren't you Ned whoa whoa whoa where do
we think we're going Maria the hottest
nurse in the world Maria Menounos wait
who's that Maria Menounos
you know what's amazing for an 80 year
old woman you'd be surprised you are
trouble
um
trouble is my middle name oh you're hot
why thank you so are you
oh my God you smell good listen when you
get off work I'll tell you what four you
meet me at 401 at the top of the
mountain I'll give you a minute to
freshen up this is yours oh my God he
just some I tried getting away with that
when I was younger how did that go for
you probably not well well it was a
while before I could come on the
internet that's for sure I've been going
over the figures again and again and and
they all add up I just don't understand
maybe I should have aborted sweet it was
a freak of nature you couldn't have
possibly predicted it let it go let it
go I'd be concerned about what happened
with your hair man yeah he's got another
Silver Streak now it's getting bigger
she's got a good thing with Victor he's
smart he's powerful he's successful
maybe you should date him then she ended
up with the right guy things worked out
for the best Victor sucks though come on
man Victor's got money yeah but like
like he's lame but money he called The
Proposal a promotion he showed her Earth
fine marry him for a year and then just
get a quick divorce
[Music]
cool
this became a totally different movie
oh man he is awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
no more kid stuff what Olympic skiers
did they get to do this I know like come
on man is he on fire he's literally on
fire
wow and they do stunts too
[Music]
great shot
that's awesome okay to join me
the women in this film man I love that
why can't more women be like yeah
I feel ya they're all super smart hot
medically knowledgeable with it
they only shoot me left side
people seem to humanizes you because you
look fake
what he's got the juice too I can tell
you guys are enjoying what was the best
part of our relationship which was
you never got it it's been two years and
all you can say is that you're happy for
me and some other guy
oh that's right it's nice to be wanted
sometimes raid so she wants to open it
yep and heard
look at me I can't look at me Sue look
at your hands what
[Music]
wow you guys hey you are never gonna
believe what just happened to me
what
ah oh my goodness I just had sex with a
really hot nurse and now I'm here to
tell you something's messed up
[Music]
but everywhere
that's what I remember
[Laughter]
[Music]
we saw Whimsical whoa
there's so many of keys to these doors
[Music]
or melt off the door handle oh yeah yeah
yeah to make your fire to oh right he's
got he's got the ew he's got the gooey
stretchy and
Gumby hands
y'all remember Gumby stretch technology
just never looked very good no this
looks like a video game hand a little
bit
[Music]
looks awesome anybody got any ideas
where the big guy's going he's going
home perfect clue everything was
destroyed but that picture I don't know
this movie kind of plays like a comic
book to me like an actual comic book
yeah it's fun I feel like I'm reading a
comic book hello
God that sounds horrifying I need you to
come out front out front
you're home baby oh she's ready for some
action she's got silk on remember when
we used to say together forever no
matter what this is the no matter what
she's gonna scream
oh man
it's me it's still me
let me explain
what a terrible wife
I don't understand she was there for the
better not the worse Greg so superficial
she only cares about looks she doesn't
want to be held at Night by a rock
oh
[Music]
you think you've got problems you take a
good look pal huh now get back to work
he said stop
it was Tuesday
[Applause]
[Music]
okay yep
you're gonna be able to stop the truck
cause you're a rock whoa
that was a really good shot awesome
[Music]
oh my goodness
oh God Saves one guy kills 20 others in
the process
or is the taxi cab that just went
straight flying here
man you could stretch your way through
oh yeah get naked
I remember this part
good movie there goes what I remember
Fantastic Four
just back away from them and uh I want
you to put your hands on your head
it's a good thing Sue's invisible yeah
like maybe do that we got food didn't we
just find a band what was the foreign
[Music]
whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
hero
wow okay all right
ah
how do they know to use these powers
[Music]
yes
that looks cool
[Music]
I got you
yeah
oh yeah goofy this looks
thank you
I don't know bravo bravo you helped good
job team you helped repair the thing you
caused yeah get down on the ground get
down on the ground now he's
oh he's like responsible for everything
that happened
[Music]
oh now she wants him back because he's a
hero in the public eye
oh nope still not she looks very
familiar yeah she works a lot
oh my God she's just like divorce time
huh she can't do it oh she did it right
there what a [__] move yeah and like at
least hand him back the ring he just
killed and saved a bunch of people yeah
[Music]
divorced hero everyone's still clapping
you think it's the Cannes Film Festival
with the amount of time they're clapping
I will do everything in my power until
there's not a breath left in me you're
gonna be Ben again she just straight up
left him she didn't even try to be like
is there a way we can fix this
fox fake news this is how you turn
things around these freaks on the front
page I was planning to use the publicity
the board's in agreement the bank's lost
enough already we're pulling out this
isn't a negotiation it's a notification
oh we're pulling out yep
in a day and age where a lot of the MCU
feels like it's made by the committee
and shot by the same people there's
something kind of refreshing about the
way this movie's shot I agree it's made
on film good old classic f-i-l-m welcome
back to the Baxter Dr Richards
day
and Lee oh thank you I didn't know
creator of Marvel Comics oh wow
now I know
I know some areas oh that's awesome I've
arranged for your things to be moved to
one of my condos thank you it's very
generous of you but I think I should
stay here with my brother
I speak so artificially to each other
yeah how much do you know about what
happened to you we need to run tests to
see the extent of the damage well you
let me know what I can do Victor wait
I love you girlfriend I will not let you
make me look like a fool if we could
understand I don't want to understand it
this isn't one of your science projects
I just want to fix it it's not that bad
of a guy you know you mean this guy in
the elevator yeah yeah I mean he's just
like trying to do right by his company
and grow money no way to take advantage
of the poor like that
oh he's silver like he hasn't done
anything that evil except that he did
cause he called The Proposal a promotion
his internal organs were completely
solid geez it's not invisibility per se
you should be able to bend light around
other objects even people if you could
control your emotional state better you
could locate the trigger yeah Lady
it's hotter than I anticipated okay
Johnny back it down
oh that John is embracing it
[Applause]
you just ruined equipment buddy
[Music]
oh I was ready for the next step you
were I think it was a little bit more
complicated than that I just wanted to
share an apartment but like always read
your head got in the way no it didn't
then what was it you're such a soap
opera your entire biophysical structure
is changing organic metallic alloy
stronger than Titanium or carbon steel
harder than diamonds I'll have to notify
the CDC talking about an epidemic here
I have a life from a face of a billion
dollar company not anymore we need to
keep this country stocks are in the Tank
Man degenerative I have to notify
someone then that's terrible news
[Music]
what a Jerk It's the infection no cause
remember he was like leave him out there
and he was gonna close the shield now I
remember a bad guy from the start
because we're like he's not that bad but
he was willing to let all those people
die oh you got to protect your money
he's throwing his doctors around you got
to protect your money but he doesn't
have any more money if I can reverse the
wave signal it'll return us back to
normal
right but what are the risks
or perhaps even kill us
so how long do these Contraptions up and
running I don't know it's hard to say
well you don't want this to get worse
worse than that guys look we're gonna be
stuck here for a while so let's just try
and get along now we're in your
quarantine this is not gonna go well
or maybe it's gonna be a lot of fun
oh
this is the part with the really fun
montage
[Music]
they put these effects to good work
I actually like seeing this movie where
it's a superhero movie where they're
trying to get rid of their powers yeah
like they see it as a curse they just
want to be human Greg like me and you
yeah it's boring
I love how he refuses to talk to Reed
and just tell him like I got [__] going
on too man
oh
[__] Revenge free uh oh get back at the
corporate overlords you're gonna be
electrocuted to death in a parking
garage
you know you could always move back to
latviri ah there it is maybe that's
where you belong
the old country
okay you die now
all right that was a good murder yeah
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness
don't look disappointed he flew and he
was also flying while on fire pretty
cool I have to give you props Johnny
[Applause]
did he add the four to it I know they
didn't put the fours on there did they
never listens oh yeah maybe he did yeah
paint he did it to all of theirs so what
are your superhero names they call me
the Human Torch is it true what they say
about him that he can expand any part of
his Anatomy
well I've always found him to be a
little wimp
what do you call that thing that turn
the thing
okay
[Laughter]
Johnny can you talk about this later
guys
thank you
these guys do so much destruction looks
like a Transformer now we need to be
careful until we're normal again what if
I don't want to be normal I didn't turn
into a monster
too far
[Music]
that is not how you hear sir
you want to fly
oh what if we got these powers for a
reason what if it's like some higher
calling a higher calling like getting
girls and making money is there any
higher
just give Reid a little more time you
know how he works analyzing every little
step before he takes one it's easy for
you to be patient no it's not I thought
I was done waiting for Reed but I I'm
still waiting We're All in This Together
Ben together you got no idea what I what
I'd give to be invisible oh that's
really sad give him some of your powers
or something or looks like do the that
too but like the blood exchange maybe I
think you can't pierce his skin though
you know oh yeah he's too rock hard for
that
[Music]
Paris left and right oh I could
look at her she's gonna be nice to him
just usual and I'm out make it a double
make it a triple
there she is
no problem
it's hotter than his wife oh you can see
me
and let me see you
can I oh
okay now being different isn't always
bad thing this ain't one of them times
not if you don't want it to be damn she
doesn't make up perfectly for a blind
woman
[Music]
how
he has hacked the cameras in his place
when are the next tests I've run out of
plants breed I should get back to work
you need a break let's go out and fall
in love again you know there is no me
and Victor never was well I guess that's
what I thought you always wanted why do
you propose them yeah there was but I'm
saying it now so take charge
[Music]
that's not fair what has he done to make
you fall back in love with him yeah
nothing he just is him he's just read
he's just his pheromones it's the
pheromones Ready's gonna fix me up okay
look he's a brilliant man we should all
you're his best friend that's what
possible reason could he have for taking
his time which he wanted in the first
place for them to get back together
remember I can't be mad about that do
you also remember what you swore to do
with every breath in your body we're
working as hard as we can yeah
I could tell
it took one break yeah I spent my whole
life protecting you and for what so you
could play Twister with your girlfriend
while I'm the freak of the whale
all right this is a 180.
that is gross interesting that's why
he's the leader all right good thing
you're flexible enough to watch your own
back cause I ain't doing it no more
but I gotta get back to the room calling
that the not the real world if you guys
are jealous that's fine I didn't expect
it to come from you though you really
think those people out there care about
you you live your life I'll live mine
guys are falling apart oh and just for
the record
they love me want to receive one
validation so Ben is that where a sex
addiction come true
down to the Fantastic two possibly one
entering testing mode now I mean you
just need to try to change Ben's power
uh-oh
is she gonna get up there and save him
but wait villain guy did something to it
oh yeah uh oh oh
okay what did you do I can make it work
no I need more power to control the
storm
Leonard bring Ben Grimm to the Baxter
building uh dang it starting to look
like Ghostbusters
but Reed said it wouldn't he also said
would avoid that storm in space but we
all know how that turned out
do you want to be Ben Grim again you
know he does
[Music]
did he do anything to the machine I
don't know that's what I was trying to
figure out because he's like I'm gonna
take
stuff away from Reed like he took
whatever away from uh
well he just gave it more power yeah is
he also trying to absorb more power
become more powerful
so I don't know
okay
yeah he had to get rid of The Bodyguard
so it's good that he's back but does
that mean he absorbed it worked
it's a cool shot oh my God what is it is
it Vic now everyone thought I was safe
behind those Shields
the machine worked for me it can work
for you too oh it did Ben it worked
perfectly okay yeah you're right he
wanted more power I've always wanted
power now I have an
Advantage Supply no thing to stand in
your way no thing the stand is sure
geez I mean if you've exposed yourself
to the storm you're endangering your
life what happens when you super hate
rubber uh
uh
[Music]
anyway you're probably able to like fly
by stretching yourself right
[Music]
friends
oh that was a cool smash cut what
happened they gotta leave me for five
minutes machine Vic used it on himself
where's Reed I think much to take
what happens to rubber when it's super
cool oh that's why I needed okay it
breaks up doesn't like you read
oh I hate it gosh it feels really purple
just a little something from our defense
contracts
let's check in on the rest of the family
shall we
whoa we gotta get out of here I got an
idea don't even think about it never do
what are you doing oh yeah
[Music]
come on come on come on
cool we have to help read
it's too dangerous for you now you have
to stay here why it seems fine but he
can't do anything he'll be he being
peace
I mean
he looks pretty oh he's gonna go back I
mean he looks like a pretty big guy he
could do some
you know I mean maybe
[Music]
his effects are pretty awesome still
come on
dive
[Music]
what was that I don't know it looked
like a thing with rocks on it in the
middle of the ocean is that how they
roll in New York City I guess
here look at at this Island full of
rocks
don't say her name so the machine works
it worked on Ben it can work on you we
can turn you back Ben's turning back
right now into a rock let's not fight no
let's
badass dialogue right there
yeah you're fired you're fired
[Music]
say goodbye
it's time to end this
yeah
you stole the line from an action figure
he must have hit just the right amount
of the radiation to make sure he can go
back to be
huh maybe next time you listen to me
before
whoa
[Music]
he's in the trash bin where he belongs
ladies I'm gonna need to borrow your car
transmission sticks not gonna be a
problem this transmission sucks
[Music]
[Applause]
there we go killing more random
pedestrians
plastic four are gonna have to fight
together I can't let you do that
and neither can I or me
come on they all got to show up she can
project a force field that far you three
are pathetic you mean four had a little
relapse huh this is gonna be fun
I can't hold
it
yes yes
[Music]
Johnny Supernova I thought we agreed
that was bad now
[Music]
whoa
you probably want to make sure
everyone's away yeah you might want to
clear out the crowd
I guess she can
oh my God what a Zinger flame on kid
oh that's some stranger things stuff
right there
[Music]
you're doing good betting
you did good torch you did good
is that the best you can do oh God this
guy what happens when you rapidly cool
hot metal hell yeah
oh
my gosh Reed turned into a slip and
slide is that what happens when you
rapidly cool hot metal uh well I need to
see I'm assuming they froze him
[Music]
cool looks like an action figure looks
like one of his statues at the beginning
it's symbolic oh there we have it
but you need he just flings back her
hair and he's like yeah
now stretch her lips out and give her a
kiss you know they were like right when
we call Action fling back your hair
Heroes
[Music]
he would need a Victor Von Doom's power
though in order to turn back
um yeah to power up the machine
I'll redo can figure that out I think if
I can rework the powers
is better than good baby really oh good
as is why would he I get this girl loves
you right or something but I found a
broken gasket from space Reed come on if
one of us were to wear it but we haven't
even seen him like turn into a better
guy for her though yet he's taking
charge okay Sue storm
will you marry me duh
she love you
soon you kind of need to
oh
yes yes are you dumbass you put the ring
on yeah the Ring went directly onto her
invisible finger did she say yes did she
take it and throw it into the ocean no
[Music]
oh there's a show about it
Protectors of New York City the
Fantastic Four
huh oh okay here we go oh see I knew it
he's not dead
I was getting the Indiana Jones
treatment how long will it be should be
about 12 days
[Music]
I think they're going to Liberia
straight up Indiana Jones yes
Tim's story that's a cool name he
directed barber shop
and the latest Shaft movie
which was a good movie Shaft was a good
movie
I don't know if there's a post-credit
scene or like another one or something I
guess not no this is telling us to move
on there's not they're telling us to get
get out of there so
Tara
my name is Tara and he knows it wow
that's some Jessica Alba acting right
there
my name is Tara and he knows it Tara
that's her acting's great uh-huh
yeah this is fun I like this movie I am
down to watch the next one it was fun I
mean there's still it the pacing of it a
little bit is it doesn't have that
Superhero pacing where you're like that
movie was dope
um but it was still a lot of fun
TV movie yeah it's like a TV movie I
feel like they could have moved just a
little bit faster maybe in the beginning
maybe that would have made it
I don't know I I don't know I don't know
what it would have made it better I felt
like there was a long time spent on like
them not doing no I'm not doing
something I'm just kind of just soap
opera yeah I I liked it more than I
remembered liking it
if that makes sense yeah because I
remember you hated it before I re I
remember being really young and just
bitching about it with the small group
of friends I was with but I don't
remember I didn't even remember how they
beat Doctor I remember like yeah they
beat Doctor Doom I don't remember
anything about like freezing him and all
that [__] uh yeah I remember the flame
on moment sure you do and you remember
when she gets naked she get naked that
was funny that's an imprint on a
adolescence brain cells right there oh
yeah going ah commit to memory form your
tastes this is what happened there she
is hot when naked this is what you will
be attracted to this is standard
Hollywood woman
um yeah I mean I thought the movie was
more fun than I remembered it initially
being and it's interesting to visit this
after the influx of MC you are that's
some familiar with you see Multiverse
Madness
yeah remember John Krasinski
yeah I my memory's bad Greg come on it
just came out like a year ago Multiverse
Madness Doctor Strange yes evil Wanda
yeah John Krasinski
do you know who John Krasinski is yeah
but like where was he in that what was
he he was the blue guy who scratches and
Wanda turns him into like spaghetti
why do I not remember this I don't know
I know I saw that movie that's the key
to the real rejects Channel you bring
people on and they know nothing they can
mirror this guy's memory right here
I saw it I remember mostly Doctor
Strange from that movie and don't they
have somebody in a case
isn't there like somebody that they have
to keep like behind bars or something
in there or am I going am I slowly going
insane I don't know maybe I I don't know
I I need to re-watch but Scarlet Witch
is the villain
yeah are you sure you saw this movie
John Krasinski was all the time anyway
let's talk about Fantastic Four I'm
rethinking my entire life right now I
don't know if I can speak to this movie
anymore well this movie was
um it was okay it wasn't great it's not
a great movie it does feel like a Disney
Channel movie at a certain point in the
first like 20 to 30 minutes I was like
you know what
this movie's fun it's it's cheesy it's
corny but it's got a colorful cast of
characters I like that it's shot on film
but for some reason in the last hour it
was right around the time when I started
telling you I kind of appreciate how
it's them dealing with you know
rejecting their powers and trying to
reverse it
it was right around there were something
switched in me it started to lose me and
it started becoming less interesting
when I started realizing they want me to
take this more serious and there's no
tension to this at all right there was
no actual real uh like you know when it
gets to the middle of like where they
hit a climax something really like big
happens and changes the characters yeah
it there wasn't really anything that big
except like maybe that bridge thing but
that was at the very very beginning of
like hey we see your powers now and then
it was really just them trying to figure
out how to fix themselves yeah a lot of
the time it went from entertaining to
being passively fun yeah yeah it's a
good way to describe it where it was
like this is a very inoffensive movie
with no tension and no Stakes when it
wants to deliver that because by the
time they get to this fight with Doctor
Doom there should be some type of like
celebration cathartic release so I was
like I don't know this guy seems like he
was kind of [__] over a lot too I mean
sure he's made some like billionaire bad
guy decisions of like no we're not
shutting this down I put a lot of money
but part of my brain was going I don't
know I kind of get where he's coming
from he put down billions of dollars
into this operation he wants to succeed
he can't just shut it down the mid in
space for 30 seconds maybe they can't
just shut it down
uh they're just trying to be like no
find a solution there's a way to fix
this so it's like he he had this
complete evil turn where
it just seemed like the movie needed him
to go completely evil right but there
was no real like there wasn't any real
juice there between him and Jessica's
character what's her name again serious
little girl yeah it was a woman don't be
invisible woman yeah she's a storm like
they only showed that when she was in
that bedroom she was gonna look through
photos but then she closes it real quick
they didn't really ever have a true
conversation of like I never loved you
I've only worked for you and you've been
a jerk or something I don't know it was
just all so on the surface between those
two which I'm like yeah it gives us
enough information of like yeah she
doesn't really like this guy this guy's
trying to like win her over with his
money and his good looks but um I didn't
feel anything for it just like I didn't
even really feel much for her and read
that much because we didn't really
revisit their relationship we know that
she was like oh you didn't want to move
in together great but there was I don't
know I I even in that moment when he
asked her will you marry me I'm like I
should I thought I think that I should
have felt something more in that moment
felt like happier like that's so yes of
course we want this but I didn't I
didn't feel that way about really any
character I didn't even feel that way
about Ben to go yes of course turn back
like even though your unit you went back
to you and it's great but now like for
the force of good you're going back to
like rock Ben like we knew he was gonna
do it but there was nothing pulling me
internally like gutterly to go that's
the right move yes I agree with you I
did not completely understand
I can't even say completely I didn't get
why at all men decided to stay the thing
I'm like really you have this option to
go back
why would it I mean I get you needed the
power set for that one moment but what
is the story of acceptance I'm not
picking up on you because they didn't
give us there was a foundation set there
of like how how has it helped Ben to
become Rock Ben and helped him more
emotionally become a better person and
that's better for him it hasn't it's
just like oh he got a girlfriend for a
second I mean like dating a blind girl
all right it's like it's sort of like
what but it's the same with all the
characters yeah they didn't really
change that much for uh once they got
the powers it didn't inherently make
them better people they just had powers
and could save people now but there
wasn't really a huge lesson learned you
know it was slowly starting to turn for
me when they they uh
yeah because I don't like I really don't
hate it I think I think the movie like I
said me neither it's good it's fun I
just like there's some stuff that I was
like why don't I feel like yay yeah it's
passively entertaining from beginning to
end like it's fun in the beginning and
then it becomes like yeah this is fine
yeah um it it was what the bridge scene
uh
started off amusing to me but when they
started treating them like Heroes
I couldn't I just got so caught up in
the fact of they're responsible for this
yeah
specifically Benton yeah he's like very
much responsible for all this
destruction and they're all like saying
you're wrong
what about all the disasters yeah for
just now that's that it was a a a slow
percolating build of of like ah movies
kind of but you know I like
I I like Chris Evans A Lot in this oh
he's great he's he gives he gives some
life yeah yeah I really like his
character a lot but again he didn't
learn much I don't think he needs to
learn much because if anything they
learn from him that's true that it's
like hey just be happy about this thing
like it's pretty cool yeah I thought
that was refreshing for a character and
then out of the four to be the one who
actually finds a lot of entertainment
and joy and celebration to come from
this I thought was a nice addition to it
and Chris evans's comedic abilities he
seems just very natural yes he's very
very natural so so great like he
elevates so much of it I agree whereas a
lot of read seems to like I think I
don't know how to pronounce this guy's
name it's either Eon gruffud or Jan
gruffin Oh I don't know but Yon gruffad
I think a lot of his scenes rely on him
having good chemistry with
um Jessica Alba
and
Jessica Alba I'm sure is a great human
being oh yeah
and still I'm sure very attractive and
very hot yeah and I'm sure there's been
some I mean she was the star of a show
called Dark Angel which I never saw but
her was solid
so I'm sure she's done some work where
she's really good yeah
she's
definitely the weakest performer here
out of the four yeah not not totally
believable in some parts she just is
kind of put in there as the girl who
says lines yeah and um
the writing did allow moments for her to
have some good emotion and some
chemistry and it's just not it's not
generated here uh she's she feels very
much like a model plucked into this role
and yeah I think with that a lot of
where you're supposed to have more heart
for Reed Richards it's going to be a
little bit void when you can't really
form chemistry with a certain actress
yeah I mean I'm sure like
chemistry was there but I do agree like
you couldn't I yeah it wasn't coming
across like on screen where they could
have pulled a lot more out of it and
maybe they just couldn't get there I
don't know yeah like I was I was not
looking forward to watching this
I wasn't I wasn't looking for it was
like Tara's coming over uh watching
Fantastic Four double all it was that
feeling of mainly you but then a little
bit of fantastic that's fine because I
just remember being young and not liking
it that I was like I and it's I don't
know if this move I want to check the
audience score because I feel like this
movie's gained
um some love over the years I know when
it first came out it was like
disastrously panned
um so let me just check here oh that
2015 one that was a bad movie oh really
I have not seen any of these yeah this
has got like a terrible race we have 45
that's all right because it's not even
like so bad it's good you know it's not
right it's not even so bad that we can
have fun ripping it apart you know right
it's just like it's such a mediocre love
land level I agree yeah yeah like like
even when he uh I think Michael Chiklis
is such a good actor but he's covered up
by like a rock the whole time his voice
changes and like he he's great
um but uh what was I gonna say but I
like that because you're thinking that
Michael checklist could have provided
more yeah like if he wasn't just a rock
guy the whole time
um yeah well apparently uh according to
Rotten Tomatoes Fantastic Four is the
next one is an improvement on his
predecessor yeah but oh it's a good 51
huh yeah okay I'll take Improvement oh
that's what I was gonna say when Michael
chiklas goes in and he but he puts the
titanium mean guy up against the wall in
his V falls on top of him and he's like
I've been waiting to do that and I'm
like it's so confusing because number
one we haven't really built up a huge
hatred for him and number two he was
just calling him Vic like 10 minutes
before that before he changed I yeah
there's just some stuff in here that I'm
like but also uh uh Michael chiklas's
character the thing whatever we call him
he wanted Reed to get back together it
was his idea in the top of the movie and
then he just lets titanium guy convince
him like they're out they're fooling
around instead of fixing you and he gets
so mad about it I don't know they're
just little plot hole that I'm like
didn't anybody like think this through
just a little bit little changes could
have made it it could have made that
line of like I've been waiting to do
that maybe pay off a little bit more
um but I didn't I was just like oh
that's awkward and maybe it's just the
pacing of the editing but I don't think
so yeah and for an ensemble piece
there's no like
great chemistry um everyone is right
you're right everyone is just very fine
with each other but there's there's no
relationship I'm really invested in
right there's no true strong chemistry
is this movie is like critically like
this is considered like a terrible film
and
I don't know I walk at least this time
walked out going
is that music yeah it's reasonably
amusing I've seen much worse here I've
seen way worse like this was fine it's
like cool it would have been better if
we had like popcorn and Red Vines and
three shots Prior to watching it and
this takes like a James gun to make this
kind of movie yeah but I'm excited for
what the MCU is gonna do with it I think
the MCU is going to do it they're gonna
do some like justice to it right they're
gonna be like this we can make this dope
they've been they've been really waiting
a long time to get it going and I'm
pretty sure because they did this and
then there's a 2015 one which went for
this like dramatic dark route and it was
not good that one I remember really well
I I saw I saw it I saw it twice actually
whoa um that one I remember really well
and that one is not good so they MCU is
really like when we do this we got to
make it right because they're they're
some of Marvel's biggest characters of
all time from the comics uh they're
their first family and so they need to
nail it and it's fun looking back at
this after
this is before the MCU you know right
before all that it was like four yeah it
was around the time like X-Men and the
Rainy Spider-Man uh the Tobey Maguire
Spider-Man movies oh yeah he was a good
fighter man he was a good Spider-Man so
it's fun looking at this and going yeah
you know it's better than some MCU
movies some MCU stuff I've seen so but
at the same time it's not it's nothing
special oh I mean yeah it's fine but I
would never be like absolutely gonna
watch that movie no if they sent me an
email and they're like would you
recommend this to friends I would have
to unfortunately go no no
not really it becomes less interesting
and play it in the background but you
don't have to pay attention yeah if it
was like laughably bad then all right
yeah but it's not even laughably no it's
not it's it's average it Teeters on
close to boring at times yeah I was a
little like I did hold back a yawn but I
couldn't figure out if it was the movie
or if I'm just tired but I want to watch
because I've heard Silver Surfer the
next one is better movie I've never seen
it I've always wanted to see it there's
constant Rumblings of Silver Surfer
coming to the big screen yeah I mean it
grows six percent to 51 and then Rotten
Tomatoes there's been a lot of because
you know with it being the Multiverse
um they bring back these characters from
the former movies there's rumors of of
Mr Fantastic here appearing in the
Deadpool 3 movie there's been rumors of
that happening for forever because it's
bringing back the Multiverse and he's
from the fox yeah so I'm like I gotta
get the whole [__] you've got to get it
all we gotta get it all in the noggin
that way we can cheer and clap when it
happens when it happens that way when he
shows up for the five seconds we go
we're like we get it I saw that thing so
I get it we put our time in and watch
those crappy movies that came before
this so we could act like we're excited
for that to be on the big screen right
now yeah yeah that's it it um but I'm
looking forward to Silver Surfer with an
open mind are you oh yeah Silver Surfer
open mind silver surfing surfing the
silver
all right guys what did you think
leave your thoughts down below follow
Tara yeah do it hey
hey my name is Tara Erickson
t-a-r-a-e-r-i-c-k-s-o-n I thought I
would spell it for him like it just in
case
it's like you know
whatever
this movie did not generate enough
energy for me to yes and you yeah it's
fine just finish with your outro okay
man
just like get her done
way to go watching the real Rejects and
don't forget to like And subscribe leave
a comment tell us how we did how you
like this movie and now
foreign
[Music]